les journées partenariales de l'action
sociale se sont déroulées aux quatre
coins de dix ans sa dernière journée
l'action sociale du conseil
départemental et les partenaires ont
invité le public à l'espace réglée du
bas de la rivière le slogan j'y passe
neuf ans en pour mieux accompagner tipa
tipa l'arrivée on a construit cette
journée avec nos partenaires et avec les
services du conseil départemental et
dont nous avons voulu justement
présenter les différentes facettes de
l'action sociale d'avant la naissance
pendant la jeunesse cela j'importe et
pour les seniors également puisque le
département intervient sur toute cette
tout ce parcours de du public en
cheminement sociales qui accompagnent
les bénéficiaires des dispositifs du
plus jeune âge jusqu'à la troisième
jeunesse montrer les actions mais
surtout montrer le travail partenarial
qui a été mise en place et qui permet
aujourd'hui une mutualisation des moyens
pour une meilleure efficacité sur le
terrain
chaque association parce qu'on va dans
la continuité ça nourrit tout de suite
une simplicité de passage ça me
contenterai la fil ont les
professionnels ont identifié repéré
aujourd'hui est bien pour nous c'est
vraiment tout objectif atteint parce
qu'on a vu plein professionnels terrain
et d'accompagnement navy à différents du
nouveau venu nous voir et chansons
un coin de notre action en raison
vouloir même si didier drogba nous
contacter voir avec lui comment est-ce
qu'ils peuvent aussi j'avais repéré ou
continuer les loups alors je pense que
ces journées sont capitales travailler
en réseau est une réalité est encore
plus une réalité de terrain
c'est pour montrer ce travail et le
valoriser que nos assistantes familiales
de la maison départementale a construit
une maison avec à l'intérieur d'autres
petites maisons ce travail ont notamment
avec plein de professionnels par exemple
va la première également
bah voilà au centre médical que nous
avons nous avons sollicité nous avons
voulu montrer les professionnels avec
lesquels les assistantes familiales sont
amenés à travailler au quotidien
et bien sûr cette liste n'est pas
exhaustive puisque nous
nous travaillons et nous continuons à
travailler avec d'autres partenaires au
quotidien et avec d'autres assistantes
familiales également on a représenté la
maison de l'assistante familiale
voilà et juste au dessus on a appliqué
aussi de petites maisons en tissu qui
justement se rapporte aux aux
partenaires comptoir et on coule qu'on
travaille ensemble et amis gip-sap et
pour info santé les visiteurs ont pu se
renseigner sur tous les dispositifs de
l'action sociale et journée placée aussi
sous le signe des changes pour permettre
à chacun de raconter son expérience sur
différents thèmes
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour
renforcer encore plus ces journées de
valorisation de l'action sociale